hi there steve coffin here again um
with my new lighting which i hope is
better
um i'm going to talk about something
that i consider very very important in
language learning and that's
feeling good okay
um
i think we all
are aware that if we
if we do something well if we have an
achievement or if if something happy
happens to us
uh it could be as as simple as as uh our
favorite sports team wins a game
or
um
you know i play old-timers hockey i
scored a nice goal
silly things but you've got a
livelier step when you're walking you
feel better about things
and
you know language learning is something
that's so dependent on the learner the
learner's attitude again i repeat you
know that it's it's the learner's
attitude number one the time you spend
with the language and your ability to
notice well not only is the attitude
itself important but it influences how
much time you're going to spend with the
language i mean if you're motivated
you'll spend more time if you're
motivated you're going to notice more
things
so that attitude is such an important
factor
and i think this is sometimes
neglected
um you know
what happens in
class teacher has a
curriculum a program that you have to
follow that certain things are taught
you're tested on them and you may not do
well on those things because
very often the things that are taught
take a while to click in that takes in
fact a lot of exposure to the language
before certain
grammatical aspects start to become
clear to you before they start to make
sense let alone before you can actually
start reproducing them so and if you do
poorly on the test then of course that's
that's discouraging and when you're
discouraged then you lose your
motivation
and so so you know i was thinking of
this for example with regard to you know
i put up videos uh at youtube in
different languages a spanish russian
you name it and invariably there is
someone who comes along and criticizes
me
there was just someone on russian who
came along and said your pronunciation
is terrible and your cases are awful and
it's pretty rough and stuff like that
which is probably true
depending on what your
standard is
compared to a native speaker i'm all of
those things and worse
however compared to someone who can't
speak the language at all which is where
i started from five years ago
and similarly with my check which is
worse than my russian which i started
let's say
you know a year and a half ago
now i'm someone who understands the
radio can read books
i have a sense of
things check things russian i listen to
their uh arguments on echo musculee i
follow the the events in czech republic
the direct election of their president
and uh whatever's going on i can follow
it in check
wow
so
you know
rather than having a teacher tell me
that my cases are wrong
or some guy gratuitously on youtube
telling me that my cases are wrong or
that my pronunciation is not very good
uh i've gotta
and we as learners have to condition
ourselves to give ourselves credit for
what we what we have achieved
i had a discussion in check the other
day and i stumbled and bumbled
but that doesn't discourage me because
of all the ways in which i am able to
enjoy the czech language
so i focus on what i have achieved wow
look i can pick up a book i can read it
i can make sense i can participate in
things check i can discuss
the the czech presidential election via
skype with a person in the czech
republic in prague
wow
so
it's very important that we find ways to
give ourselves credit so that we have a
sense of achievement because that sense
of achievement is is very encouraging
for us and it keeps us going
and you know if you're at school for
example if the
say french
program is discouraging because you're
you're getting poor marks or whatever
this carries over into other subjects in
other words any success that we feel in
our language learning makes us more
positive in other areas of endeavor so
if we are satisfied with what we have
achieved in our say independent learning
of a language
that makes us better at other things
that we do so what i'm getting at on all
of this is that
very often traditional language learning
focuses on testing you focuses on on
trying to make sure that what was taught
to you that you have in fact learned it
and i think that's largely
counterproductive
obviously we need testing in maths or in
in uh you know engineering or or you
know like a brain surgeon or people like
that that have to meet certain standards
but what are we looking for in in
language acquisition
except for a small minority of people
who are going to be translators or
interpreters at the u.n or something
most people just want to communicate
and so it's important to bear in mind
that these are the goals the person who
wants to work towards that ultimate goal
of sounding like a native which i don't
think is feasible for 99 of people
or speaking correctly and stuff is good
and those are laudable goals and we need
to have those goals but we need to give
ourselves credit we need to feel
comfortable confident feel good about
our
learning and teachers should make that
their number one goal is to make the
learner feel good about his or her
learning so that they have a positive
attitude feel confident put in the time
enjoy it
try to make the language their own all
those things
so it's just um
you know i had a conversation today with
someone i was explaining link to them
this was a potential corporate
customer for link and they sort of said
well
you know what is the pedagogical you
know
basis for what you do and and with
credentials and all this kind of stuff
um
yeah
we're a group of people we help each
other
native speakers helping others learn
the language of that native speaker
lots of interesting content people enjoy
what they do they put in the time they
learn
that's the pedagogical basis it's not no
world you know she's this person said
you have to have
the uh you have to teach the basic
structures it has to be the structured
that structured and i as i've said many
times i find it very difficult to learn
the basic structures i don't think the
basic structures just slot into place
like that i think eventually over time
with enough exposure you get a better
and better sense of how the language
works but you don't just go out there
and acquire the basic structures i don't
think it works that way
rather
what happens in our schools is
a lot of people are discouraged by the
way languages are taught and they never
continue they never continue once they
leave school they don't bother with it
and so that's a great feeling so
just to summarize again i think language
instruction should focus on the issue of
making the learner feel good about
learning that language wanting to learn
that language
feeling good about their achievements
rather than
pointing out through tests or through
other critical comments where the
learner
isn't quite
up to
somebody else's standard so i hope that
makes sense thank you thanks for
listening bye for now